you guys know what place is really quiet
right now what the theaters we're gonna
watch from how it should have ended is
he a quiet place comedy recap let's do
this VPNs
[Music]
enter Pennywise
[Music]
[Music]
you guys wanna dance
ha
live your best life oh man oh okay
[Laughter]
[Music]
are you serious healthy why
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
pants are cool yes it is like we've
talked about a VPN recently on a
different video what was it called what
was it SiteLock VPN what people want to
do right now in the States
I think the only one of these I've seen
before is the predator won the comedy
dubs there I think what makes this one
so funny for variety reasons like kudos
to the voice actors and this the
dialogue was of course hilarious you did
so was I sing out but just the overall
conceit of it and choosing to do a
comedy dubs on a quiet place works so
well because there's such little
dialogue in the film so beyond just
replacing dialogue they're able to fill
in a lot of comedic moments with inner
thoughts that they might have been
having and then put it into dialogue so
I thought the idea to place this segment
on a quiet place works so well and that
also gives them a chance to really poke
even more holes in a quiet place that I
never thought about before
like when they just have the baby
they're downstairs and that will leave
ones like where's our other children out
we're so focused on the baby that we're
not even thinking about hey they got two
other kids you gotta look after and if
they got killed they'd have to get
pregnant two more times
Yeah right well on that that one gripe
that everyone always brings up which is
why don't you live by the river live by
the waterfall words loud you know why I
don't really get fully on board with
that argument because to move to the
river you have to create even more noise
building a house building a house but
then also brain stuff getting worse yeah
yeah it's too much at risk to travel
over there when having to lug stuff you
know just and so I think that it of
itself makes it challenging to get to
the rivers I've heard that forever I
used to be on board for it but then
whenever I rewatched it I was like you
know if they're probably really
challenging again stuff they're
discreetly and as quietly as possible
yeah just let outside by the river yeah
that's what I mean cookin stuff yeah I
have to find ways to survive and what if
it gets really cold outside
yeah you shouldn't eat that much fish
you know every single yeah I love the
foreshadowing character - oh my god
little eyes and mouth they put on the
nail and and the way they even bothered
to have it gets sad when they avoided at
the end yeah I love that they made a
character out of everything and yet you
pointed out I think there are a lot more
than I even realized at first but yeah
giving the aliens a voice to and making
them just sort of like people who just
want to come visit and check yeah well I
guess the thing is I think a quiet place
is a nice subject to do that with
because it's a premise that opens you up
to so much situations remedy you can
change the stakes and I love that in a
lot of these dubs a story arises that's
not the original story and I like that
with his e dubs they just kind of make
their own dialogue over and they don't
necessarily feel the need to either
censor an obvious word sounds like a
specific swear in certain other videos
like that I feel like it can create one
kind of
reliably whereas this is like the
daughters mostly as mad she didn't get
to go fishing yeah I didn't get to do
any of this stuff with John Krasinski we
are the worst yeah that was a lover they
gave him like a southern accent for the
yeah I guess I mean I don't remember
what he sounds like just house like a
drunk yeah alright guys what do you
think of this hizzy video leave your
thoughts down below what other movies do
you want them to do it dubs full mmm as
human centipede to subscribe to the real
rejects subscribe to his eek lick the
notification Bell mob but how could we
end this without a Alfred Benjamin
threats the third three names and he's
the third isn't that interesting not
common with people with the third at the
end of their name yeah ^ 9 now Alfred is
just as handsome and loyal as someone
like a penny worth as creative as
someone like a Franklin and as
threatening as politicians very specific
kind of read he's not gonna come and
Menace you physically she's gonna
undermine everything that you stand for
see how hard it is to shout you out when
you don't get back to us by the way
thanks for pledging or patreon page but
I sent you a message because we've got
to get personalized shoutouts yeah it's
pretty challenging unless you message me
back so here's what I'm hoping you catch
this shout out so next month we can give
you another one or if you don't care
about how we shout you out then I'll
just say this message just back or else
yeah that's a threat that you can stand
by because otherwise these are just
gonna get more and more off-road and
then pretty soon I mean people are gonna
have a whole other idea of who you are
and there are other Alfred Benjamin
threats out there and then you're gonna
affect there you know it's like you're
your lineage is going to be tainted by
the fact that you never got back see
what happens you don't matter you
wouldn't have access then you gotta have
me and provide absence and no one wins